grosse différence au niveau des iphone
c'est la première fois qu'apple il ya
mettre une pluie d'une ancienne
génération sur un nouveau modèle sur les
iphone 14 et 14 plus on va retrouver la
15e bionique qui avait déjà été présenté
sur les iphone 13 alors pour autant
c'est une très bonne puce est ce que
sont les modèles professionnels on
retrouve la cèze bionique à 5 14 pro a
et 114 pronax c'est un choix qui est
très surprenant de la part d'apple ce
qu'ils ont vraiment voulu marquer une
différence entre les modèles d'iphone 14
normaux et les modèles professionnels
probablement au cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que cette puce à 15 blonie qu'elle
fonctionnait déjà très très bien l'année
dernière on sonnera aussi très bien
cette année les mettre plus de 1000
euros dans un nouveau smartphone est à
voir à la puce de l'année dernière même
si elle était probablement on peut
améliorer ça est quand même surprenant
sais pas ce que vous en pensez dites le
moi dans les commentaires et puis pour
tout savoir l'achitecte vous invite à
venir vous abonner